Camille Sanschagrin possède deux poules
pondeuses dans ce poulailler d'été
installé au bout de son terrain en plein
cœur de l'arrondissement Rosemont la
Petite Patrie c'est quoi le
quotidien
de l'animal en tout cas ils sont
interdits
la SPCA déplore ne pas avoir été
consultée par la ville centre ou par les
arrondissements l'organisme qui reçoit
une trentaine de poule abandonné par
année demande un moratoire sur
l'émission des permis
et les spécialistes dans la SPCA de
Montréal
responsabilité plus importante que l'on
peut vivre
et au niveau de la peau
il est possible que certaines citoyens
décide de s'en débarrasser
regarder soins spécialisés
SPCA constate également que toutes les
villes américaines et canadienne qui ont
permis la présence de poules en ville et
ils ont tout vu une augmentation
importante du nombre de c'est oiseau
dans la fourrière est dans le refuge
Issigeac Bissonnet Radio-Canada Montréal